Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in the
divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you my beloved divine
will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will
so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure,
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels
and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the holy spirit
and infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. As usual, the Lord has provided a great feast for us this evening. So we're beginning
on May the 31st 1926. And the Lord is going to repeat some lessons he has already given to us.
That's the way he works. And so he wants to make absolutely certain that we know the difference
between somebody actually living in the divine will and somebody just simply submitting to the
divine will. There are two entirely different ways of living. One is living in God and the other is
living outside of God in his kingdom because living in God is inside in the divine will and the other
one is simply obeying his laws. So Louisa says the light of the divine will continues to envelop me
and my little intelligence while swimming in the immense sea of this light. Now notice how deeply
Louisa is experiencing her union in the unity of the light of the divine will now that you have
the new language. But she said, even though I am swimming in the immense sea of this light,
I can only barely take a few drops of light and a few little frames of all the many truths and
knowledge and happiness that the endless sea of the eternal will contains. She's going to explain
that. But the reason is that we are so small. We are so tiny. The solar system itself is only a
speck of a speck of a speck in the universe. So I mean, how do you measure us? So she explains
that anything she tells us is nothing to what is actually there. She can only take a very small
amount. And many times I cannot find the right words to put it on paper. Even that little bit so
I want to give you one Corinthians two nine there. I had not seen nor ear heard or has entered into
the heart of man to conceive what God has prepared for those who love him. She said, I say a little
by comparison with the amount that I leave out because my little and poor intelligence takes
as much as can fill me. I have to leave the rest out. And then she gives the example of a fish in the
sea or a person in the sea. She said, take a person who dives into the we would say the ocean.
And he gets all wet. Water flows everywhere. Maybe even in his bowels. He'd be in grave danger of
not coming out of the sea if he had that. And as he goes out of the sea, how much of all that water
of the sea does he carry? Very little. You've got a few drops all over your skin. Indeed, almost
nothing compared to the amount of water that actually remains in the ocean. And by having been
in the ocean, can he perhaps say how much water is there? Are our many species of fish or what
quantities of them there are in the sea? He can't. He has experienced the immensity of the sea,
but he can't really talk about it. And that's what she's saying. Such is my poor soul. Now,
when I was really thinking about this, the talk that came to me was we, you and I, need to be careful
not to make big claims about our little experience of the divine will. Because if Louisa's
huge experience of the divine will puts her into position of being able to say so little,
although we think she said an awful lot, we've got to be very careful that we're now making claims
of having arrived at some crown of sanctity or that we have reached the fourth degree or whatever
degree there is. We've got to be very careful. In fact, humility is extremely important and
that we make no claims at all. Then Louisa said, while I was still in this light, my sweet Jesus
came out from within my interior. So that's one Corinthians 3 16 and Luke 17 21, the kingdom of
goddess within you. And he said, my daughter, this is the unity of the light of my will. So that's
been explained last week. I'm not going to go over it again. And so that you may love it more and
be confirmed more and more in it. Now notice that we have got to develop all the time now to be
confirmed in it. It's wanting to dip your foot in the ocean. It's quite another matter to do some
scuba diving. It's quite another matter to do deep sea swimming. It's quite another matter to say
there. So that you would be more and more confirmed in it. That is confirmed in living in the divine
will at every nano second of your life. I want to make known to you the great difference which
exists between one who lives in my will in the unity of its light. That's why I said living in
God and one who resigns and submits themselves to my will. That means obeying orders completely
different in order to make you understand this well. I'm going to give you an example. He said,
the simile is from the sun which is on your horizon. The sun being in the vault of the heaven
spreads its rays over the whole surface of the earth. Look between the earth and the sun there
is some sort of an agreement. Now he's introduced the comparison between the sun and the earth. The
sun represents living in the divine will and the earth represents living submitted to the divine
will and this comparison is very clear. Between the earth and the sun there's a sort of agreement.
The sun touches the earth and the earth receives. Now notice the sun is giving and the earth is
receiving. So the earth receives the light and receives the touch of the sun. Now by receiving
the touch of the light by submitting, notice the word, to the sun. The earth receives the effects.
Now when you come across a word like this you really got to look it up and an effect is something
that's produced by something else and to be effective means that you become productive. That
means capable of producing a result and that's what the Lord is saying that the effect of the sun
on the earth makes the earth productive. It makes it capable of producing results. He's going to
tell us that the earth would be a terrible place if the sun didn't do that. By giving of its effects
the sun does not give its light. Now notice light is the essence of the sun. The sun doesn't give
its light. It just gives the effects of the light. On the contrary Jesus said the sun
generously preserves its unity and its effects are not lasting. And therefore one sees the poor
earth at one stage all flowery in the summertime and then stripped in the wintertime. It changes
almost every season. If you're in Ireland it changes every day. If the sun gave the earth the effects
and the light the earth would change into a sun because it would have the source and it would
no more need to beg for the effect because containing the light within itself it would become the
owner of the source of the effect. Now he's showing you there how we can change from being people who
are outside of this wonder of living in the depths of the blessed Trinity simply obeying his laws
and gradually coming into it and taking possession of that source which is the divine will itself.
And he keeps on saying if you're living in the divine will you must have possession.
Okay then you become the source then you become a source and the effects that are coming from you
will have wonderful effects on other people. So you have first of all living in God which is living
in the unity of the light of the divine will and the second one is living outside of that reality
but submitting to the orders of God most high but you can change because you have free will.
You can choose one or the other. So in the next paragraph he's going to tell us that the soul
is the earth and lives from the effects of the divine will and then in the paragraph that follows
that but you can change. So I want you to put if you have your own notebook I want you to put A
here and B on the next one because you can change you can go into the divine will you have free will
you can choose it. So first of all the soul has earth living from the effects of the divine will
which is the position of all good people who don't know about the divine will and they are trying to
do God's will to the best of their ability. It's more than the majority it's 99 percent of humanity
who know God. Now such is the soul who resigns and submits to my will. She lives off the effects
contained in the divine will. The divine will is outside notice she's outside of it not possessing
the light that's the divine will that's the son not possessing it she does not possess the source
of the effect contained in the son of the eternal volition and therefore she looks almost like
the earth sometimes she's rich in virtues and sometimes poor in other words a person like this
fluctuates and one of the things that can scandalize people is that if a person is known to be religious
or to be holy I say holy and inverted commas that if you lose your patience with something that
happens or they're all scandalized because they expect you to be perfect and so you've got this
fluctuation like the earth sometimes rich sometimes poor if she changes at every circumstance there's
the weather change even more if she's not always resigned and submitted to my will look at the little
word always that means every moment of every day if she's not always resigned but you see somebody
living outside of the divine will at a distance from it only obeying they don't have the same grace
as those who are living inside of it empowered by the divine will to live this wondrous life
so even more if she's not always resigned and submitted to my will she'd be like the earth that
doesn't want to let itself be touched by the light of the son in fact if the earth receives the effects
it's because it allows itself to be touched by the light this is extremely important and why you have
all the spiritual writers before the divine will saying that you must surrender you must open up
you must receive you must expose yourself to the grace of god you must allow him to actually touch
you because we all know people who can just absolutely close up and you can't get through it all okay so
at this particular stage it's extremely important to be open to god's grace and you know the amazing
thing is that the most unlikely people are so she will receive its effects because the earth
lets itself be touched by its light otherwise it would remain squalid and unable to produce even a
single plane of grass this is the way adam remained after sin i'm changing that sentence because
it's not in okay and it's the same if we sin and go out of the divine will so for that i want to
give you one john two three and one john three six and i go to let you look them up because there isn't
time so that's the way adam remained after sin he lost the unity of the light that's the divine will
and therefore he lost the source of the goods and effects which the son of my will contains so he
moved out of the divine will he's outside of it so i want to make that very very clear tonight
you're either inside living in the heart of the trinity or you're outside simply obeying or trying
to obey adam could no longer i want you to notice this now there's something here that's very important
adam could no longer feel the fullness of the divine son within himself he could no longer
see within himself that unity of the light which his creator had fixed in the depths of his soul
and which communicating his likeness to him made of him his faithful copy now notice here that the
lord is saying that if you're living in the divine will you know it you actually perceive it and
that's the feel and the see you actually know it you can't be living in the the depths of the divine
will and actually not know it if you have no sense of it you're probably outside so he could no longer
feel the fullness he could no longer see within himself that unity of the light and this whole
message started with louise swimming in the sea of the divine will and feeling and seeing and
understanding and reaching out and experiencing this is the opposite you go out of it and you don't
have any of this experience so before sinning what people call pre-lapsarian adam i love the
big long word you know before sinning adam possessed the source of the unity of the light of his creator
in other words he possessed the divine will and so each little act of his was a ray of light now acts
in the divine will are divine coming from the source of light which is the son of the divine will
and therefore they are rays of light which invading the whole of creation went to fix itself in the
center of its creator bringing to god the love and the return for all that had been made for adam
in the whole of creation so here's the response of divine will acts giving back to god they i love
you i adore you i praise you i bless you i thank you in my name and the name of all creation so god
gets a response from creation through this person okay adam was the one who harmonized everything and
formed a note of accord now i want you to notice this now because a couple lines further on he's
going to be called the clashing note the note of accord between heaven and earth is that somebody
is living in the divine will therefore heaven can operate on earth but as soon as he withdrew from
my will his acts no longer invaded heaven and the earth like rays they shrank because they just
simply become human next them almost like plants and flowers within the circle of this field so
losing the harmony of all creation genesis too is quite clear about that that creation went into
chaos adam became the clashing note so from the note of accord he becomes the clashing note in the
whole of creation oh how low he descended and he cried bitterly over the lost unity of the light
which raising him above all created things made of adam the little god of the earth
that is sam eight five to six you've made him little less than a god with glory and honor you
crowned him gave him power over all the works of your hands sam 82 verse six which jesus quoted
in john 10 34 i said you are gods all of you sons of the most high and sons of the most high
was the biblical way of describing angels so the difference between living in the depths of the
heart of god and living outside of it are actually very clear there so now we go on to the next one
which i'm calling b that was a the soul as the earth now we have in the next paragraph b i'm
calling it we have the soul as son she lives in the source of the divine will the source of everything
now my daughter from what i've just told you you can understand that the living in my will
means to possess the source of the unity of the light of my will that's like saying i own the son
and so you possess the source and with it you have with all the fullness of the effects contained
in it that's why you keep on hearing jesus saying to louisa everything that is mine is yours
everything that is yours is mine complete surrender to each other so the person living in the divine
will possesses the source of the unity of light and also possesses in its fullness all the effects
contained in it so light love adoration all of this arise in each act of the creature which
constituting itself the act of each act love for each love like solar light invades everything
harmonizes everything centralizes everything within itself so it wants to lift absolutely
everything to blaze them with the divine will and to bring back to god all the praise and honor and
glory and thanksgiving and everything else so like solar light she invades everything harmonizes
everything centralizes everything within itself and like a shining ray the soul brings to her
creator the return for all that he has made for all creatures now if you have your page open in front
of you in the last paragraph you were told that adam was able to do this for himself and for all
of creation that's because adam was at the beginning of humanity but now there's eight billion people
on the planet we're able to do it for everybody for all creatures and not only present today but in
the past and in the future as well so we in fact cover much more than adam covered at the time he
was alive so gives god a return for all that he has made for all creatures of all time and gives
god the true note of accord now notice that adam had a note of accord before the fall but the person
in the divine will has the true note of accord why does he distinguish one from the other because in
the beginning adam had not been tried and tested those of us who have entered into the divine will
now have been tried and tested and you've had to make a choice and you've had to come back you've
had to let the lord bring you back piece by piece and so you become the true sons of god that's
Romans 8 19 okay this is actually a greater gift god always gives something greater and greater and
greater when he's challenged he never just gives what he gave before that's why the church sings
well happy fault of adam that gave us so great a redeemer what a difference between one who possesses
the source of the goods which the son of my will contains and the one who lives from the effects
of it so there you have again the huge difference it is the difference that exists between the sun
and the earth so the sun is the image of the one living in the divine will the earth the image of
the one living outside of it the sun always possesses the fullness of its light and the effect
it is always blazing and majestic in the vault of the heavens nor does it need the earth
this the other way around while it touches everything it is untouchable
now this is going to be important as we move on in the message this evening
it does not let itself be touched by anyone you'll notice that the sun is at a safe distance from us
so that we can't interfere with it although scientists are attempting at the moment
and to be very interesting to see what happens because the lord says it's untouchable it does
not allow itself to be touched by anyone now we're going to hear this with regard to the divine will
in the following message if anyone dared even to fix on it it would eclipse and blind him
and knock him down with its light in other words you can't really look at the sun without your
eyes being damaged on the other hand the earth is in need of everything the earth is need
it lets itself be touched and stripped and if it wasn't for the light of the sun and its effects
it would be a gloomy prison full of squalid misery therefore there's no comparison
that holds between one who lives in my will and one who submits to it
now if anything should make a person jump over into the divine will you have it there
so in the next paragraph the damage done through adam's fall was so great that only a divine person
could actually redeem it could repair the damage before sinning adam did possess the
unity of the light but he could no longer recover it repentance to see couldn't get him to recover it
he couldn't recover it during his life it happens to him as to the earth that turns around the sun
not being fixed in turning around it opposes the sun and forms its light bit like the human will
at one stage cooperate in the next stage opposes now in order to render humanity firm again
so i don't see man because there's the whole of humanity that has to be redeemed in order to
render humanity firm again so that he might sustain the unity of this light now look of what is an
issue once we go into the darkness and sin and selfishness we are no longer able to sustain
the light of god's presence i've always been fascinated by a certain number of people
whom you will notice at funerals in particular where they don't even go into the church they're
not able to actually get themselves physically into the church to stay outside and some of them
stay at quite a distance i'm amazed that i have witnessed funerals where some of the people attending
the funeral are not even in the church grounds they're across the road close to one of the shops
looking at a distance but as far as they're concerned they're at the funeral and there are
others and they can go right up to the altar and they have no problem at all people don't realize
what they're telling you by their actions so for humanity to be able to sustain the presence of
god you see is the unity of the light a repairer was needed now that's the savior and this savior
had to be superior to man had to be because a divine strength was needed in order to straighten
them up here's the necessity for redemption so then he goes on to speak about our blessed
mother having the unity of the light my celestial mother also possessed the unity of this light
and this is why more than son she was able to give light to all it was never nighttime for her
you see nighttime happens for the earth it doesn't happen for the sun nor was there ever a shadow
between her and the supreme majesty it was always full daylight so for those of you who are doing
the book of revelation with me and we've now arrived at the new Jerusalem where they don't need sunlight
because it's a full daylight then i think you would call her the queen of the new Jerusalem
therefore in each instant of her life this unity of the light of my will made the whole
of the divine life flow within her that means god fully operated and flowed in her
we might be able to say that in words but to take it on board is different matter it would be very
transforming for us and because the whole of the divine light flowed within her there was nothing
blocking it this brought her seas of light joys and happiness divine knowledge seas of beauty glory
and love in other words god flowed her with everything that he had to make her like him and more and
more like him and she as though in triumph brought all these seas to her creator as her own
to attest to him her love her adoration and charm him with her beauty and the divinity
made more and more and more beautiful seas flow in her so the more she gave back the more he gave
and we've heard that over and over throughout the volumes that the more we give to god he doubles it
and then we give him back and so on she possessed so much love that as though naturally she could
love all she could adore and she could make up for all her littlest acts that would be sweeping the
floor or something down in the unity of this light were superior to the greatest acts and to all the
acts of all creatures put together why because the fullness of the divine life was flowing in her
and through her and so you have this divine light and love flowing through her in the most
extraordinary way therefore the sacrifices the works the love of all other creatures can be called
little flames we would say little candles before the sun holding a little lighted candle before
full sunlight would be a little bit foolish yet hardly noticing was lighting they would be like
little drops of water before the ocean compared to the acts of the sovereign queen and this is why
as a consequence of the unity of the light of the supreme volition she triumphed over everything
knows it's as a consequence by virtue of okay so i want to give you Philippians 4 13 i can do all
things in christ i can't do all things outside of him outside of him i can do nothing john 15 5
without me you can do nothing it's because the fullness of the flow of the divinity is operating
through her all the time that she can be the triumph over everything and she was able to conquer her
very creator making him a prisoner in her maternal womb i find it very interesting that he uses the
term prisoner because when you go to what louisa says about the sufferings of jesus in the womb
it might be referring to that and so he says only the unity of this light of my will which she who
ruled over everything possessed it's because she possessed it yes she was able to rule over everything
was able to form this project which had never occurred before administering to her acts worthy
of this divine prisoner so everything she does because she is living in the unity of the divine
will because she's living in the heart of the trinity because the whole of the divine life is
flowing in her everything she does all her acts thoughts words acts move and steps everything
everything is worthy of her divine prisoner so she's the ark of the covenant she's the tabernacle
holding this treasure and god made it worthy of him so now we come back to adam in the next
paragraph by losing the unity of this light the lord is trying to get us to understand the enormity
of what happens when you're living in the heart of the divine will which our blessed mother was
and the enormity of the fall if you come out of it and i think in the present challenging
circumstances this is a very timely message by losing this unity of light adam turned himself
upside down and he formed night as he was all day for her he formed weakness he formed passions
for himself and for all the generations it's the original sin if this virgin queen had done
nothing else but preserve the unity of the light of the eternal volition in the depth of her immaculate
soul this would have been enough to give back to us the glory of all and the acts of all
now look at the enormity of what happened to him when he came out of the divine will
i missed a little bit there she made the day of the son of justice arise for all generations
now for the son of justice i want to give you maliki four two
so we would say even if she had done nothing she had done everything because she would make up
for all the acts of everybody because her love was so great that has been described earlier
through her by virtue of my will or as a consequence of living in the depths of the blessed trinity
the divinity felt come back to itself the joys and the happiness which it had established to
receive through creation now in the messages coming up i want you to notice every now and then
that god had established to happen everything has been predetermined in that one act that sovereign
act i call the singularity that one act of god and so god established that if he made the whole of
creation that this was the return that creation should give to him and thanksgiving and so on
and she was able to do it by herself which is amazing therefore she can be called queen
she can be called mother she can be called foundress she can be called the base on which
everything else is built she can be called the mirror of my will in which all can reflect themselves
to receive its life from her so in the next two paragraphs we've just been told that the
raising up of the human race required a divine repairer so we're going to talk about this divine
repairer we're going to talk about the incarnation of the word so louisa said after this i felt as though
soaked with this light that's a very interesting expression we would say soaked with water we would
say inundated with this light but the translation is saying soaked with light i can't explain that
and i understood the great prodigy of living in the unity of this light of the supreme volition
so let's use a different expression for soaked enveloped in this light so enveloped in this light
she understood the points that he was trying to get across to her
and my sweet jesus coming back at it my daughter added in the state of innocence
and my celestial mother possessed the unity of the light of my will not by their own virtue that's
extremely important no creature could have this by their own virtue this is pure gift this is the
gift of the divine will without him we can do nothing john 15 5 it was by sheer grace that he
gives us the gift of the divine will none of us can deserve it not even our blessed mother
for her to receive the incredible gift that she received at the instant of our conception her son
had to die redemption had to happen she was a daughter of adam so the lord had to die for her
as well as adam adam and our blessed mother possessed the unity of the light of the divine will but
not by their own virtues pure gift it was by virtue communicated by god you see the word virtue is
being used wrong all the time it was by sheer gift sheer grace on the other hand my humanity possessed
it now it is the light of the supreme volition the unity of the light of the supreme volition
jesus's humanity possessed that by its own virtue in other words it was because he was divine
it didn't have to be given to him because in his humanity there was not only the unity of the light
of the supreme volition i can't get all the words out as you can see trying to say it but there was
the eternal word he's divine as well as human and since i am inseparable from the father and the
holy spirit the true and perfect by location occurred now before we go on the inseparability of father
and son in the holy spirit is john 10 29 and verse 38 so because you cannot separate the persons of
the blessed unity or the divine will in the father in the son and in the holy spirit there's only one
divine will therefore the perfect by location occurred that means that while jesus became man
he was also in heaven and while i remained in heaven i descended into the womb of my mother
and since the father and the holy spirit are inseparable from me again john 14 9
they too descended into it at the same time they remained in the heights of the heavens
so miry's the ark of the covenant she's the temple of god she's the tabernacle of the most
high okay now because of what's just being said here about this perfect by location
if you go back and read some of the meditations of the saints i am at this particular moment thinking
of dumb marmian some of his wonderful meditations when it came to the incarnation and the birth of
jesus one of the things that he brought out clearly was that while jesus in his humanity
needed everything that an infant needed at the same time he was keeping the universe going and he
was receiving souls in death and he was judging souls in their particular judgment so he was bringing
out the fact that he was in heaven and on earth at the same time but if you think that through
you will realize that living on the earth must have been extremely painful for him meeting all
the sin and the rebellion and all the rest of it that was on the earth must have been extremely
painful for him so make you understand more his suffering during his lifetime so we continue
with the incarnation of the word now while jesus was saying this the doubt came to me about whether
the three divine persons had suffered i mean who was on the cross all three of them are the
word alone now she explained to us a couple of weeks ago that the lord often puts these doubts
into our head so that he can answer them for the rest of us and jesus resumed speaking and said
my daughter because they are inseparable from me the father and the holy spirit descended with me
and i remained with them in the heavens there's the perfect by location but the task of satisfying
of suffering and of redeeming was taken by me we would say alone okay i the son of the father took
on the role of reconciling god with man i'm just going to give you three references there out of
many Colossians 1 20 Ephesians 2 16 and Romans 5 10 okay our divinity was untouchable by the
suffering of the slightest pain it was my humility that united with the three divine persons in an
inseparable way placed itself at the mercy of the divinity suffered on herd of pains because you
know that in the hours of the agony in gethsemane jesus suffered from the divinity and then the others
and therefore his pains are divine as well as human suffered on herd of pains and satisfied
in a divine manner and that was what was required that to raise humanity up to a level of being
able to live in the divine will he had to satisfy for that and since my humanity possessed not only
the fullness of my will as its own you see the word virtue coming up again as its own possession
but the word himself as well as the father and the holy spirit as a consequence of our inseparability
it surpassed in a more perfect way both innocent adam and my very mother so what jesus is talking
about is the hypostatic union that is the union between the father the son and the holy spirit
it's difficult for us to try and grasp it because it is such sublime stuff but when he said it surpasses
both innocent adam and our blessed mother it is the difference between nature and grace
they received the gift of the divine will by grace he has it by nature he's the source of it
and that's why he talks about himself as the springing fount which we're going to meet in
a sentence or two so in fact in them that is in adam and in our blessed mother both of them creatures
it was grace i call it sheer grace in me it was nature so here again i want to give you acts
2024 Romans 1 5 Romans 16 20 etc there's an awful lot
so it was nature for jesus it was grace for them they had to draw light grace power beauty from god
in me there is the springing fount of light john 8 12 i am the light okay in me there was the springing
fount of light of beauty and grace so the grace they received comes to him so for our blessed mother
to receive the extraordinary grace she received in her conception that grace came from her son
so the difference between me as nature and my very mother as grace was so great because the
difference between the divinity and a creature that she remained eclipsed before my humanity
now we'll explain why the mystics like louisa and maria val torta speak of this extraordinary
relationship that existed between them jesus and his mother therefore my daughter be attentive
your jesus possesses the springing fount he's the source he's the origin so i want to give you
sam 36 verse 9 and sam 74 verse is 15 and 16 so jesus is the springing fountain and has always
something to give and you have always something to receive because there's heaven and earth
being illustrated there earth receives heaven gives as much as i might tell you about my will
there's always something more how can we understand god we can't he says neither the short life of the
exile or the whole of eternity will be enough to make known to you the long story of the divine will
now i'm going to start the next message and i'll definitely have to go over the time because
this is a long message as well so jesus wants us involved he wants us participating
it's just astonishing that he is prepared to turn to little nothings and ask for their cooperation
louisa said i was doing my acts in the supreme will according to my usual way and i tried to trace
everything that my jesus my celestial mother in creation and all creatures did now that's a tall
order if you've tried to do this now while i was doing this my sweet jesus helped me there's your
Philippians 4 13 i can do it in him i can't do it outside of him he helped me by making present to
me all of his acts which i omitted to trace not having the capacity to do it and jesus all goodness
would make his act present to me telling me my daughter in my will all of my acts are all present
because anything that is done in the divine is it's present it never disappears
and he said like it's if they were all lined up together look here are all the acts of my
childhood they're all my tears my wailings there's also when as a little child i picked flowers while
walking through the fields come to place your i love you on the flowers i pick and on my hands
that stretch out to pick them it was you that i looked at in these flowers that's amazing isn't it
when she hadn't come into being it was you that i picked as a tiny little flower of my will
don't you want then to keep me company with your love in all my acts as a child i'm using yourself
with me in these innocent acts keep looking there is where as a little child tired from crying for
souls so there he is interceding for souls even as a small very small child i would take some very
short sleep how unnatural for us but before closing my eyes i wanted you so that you might
favor my sleep first i wanted to see you kiss my tears by impressing your i love you on each tier
and to have made close my eyes to sleep with the lullaby of your i love you but do not leave me alone
while i sleep wait until i wake up so that just as you closed my sleep you may open my vigil in
your i love you now notice he wasn't just playing around like other children it's a vigil that means
that he is continuing his mission of intercession for souls and sacrificing for souls is going on
all the time that's the part of it that is not usually considered what Jesus did in his childhood
and his adolescence and young life my daughter watch this now i hope you have your pen out
one for whom it was established that she should live in my will
that means your call to live in the divine will is ab a eternal from all eternity you have been
called to live in the divine will this is an absolutely astonishing grace long before you existed
or your ancestors existed for one for whom it was established that she should live in my will
was inseparable from me and even though at that time you weren't even there my will made
you present before you were conceived and gave me your company and your acts and your i love you
and you know what and i love you in my will means that i love you in closes an eternal happiness
a divine love so when we give him our i love you in the divine will we're giving him an eternal
happiness something that is right for him a divine love which is the only love that is worthy of him
and for my tender age that was enough to make me happy and to form a sea of joy around me
enough to make me put aside all the bitterness of what other people gave me
if you don't follow me in all of my acts there will be a void in your acts
in my will and i will remain isolated without your company now notice how complete he wants us
to enter he wants us involved in all of creation all of redemption and all of
sanctification but i want your link with everything i have done now the only way you can get that
into your head is to take it off the page and write it on another piece of paper so you actually see
it i want your link with everything i have done because since the will that unites us is one as
a consequence our acts must be one but keep following me look at me here when at the tender age of two
or three we're not talking about him as 12 or 13 i would withdraw from my mother and kneeling with
my little arms stretched in the shape of a cross i prayed to my celestial father that he would
have pity on mankind this is a massive insight into the hidden life and in my open little arms i
embraced all generations my position was excruciating so little on my knees with my arms stretched out
crying and praying my mother could not have endured seeing me her maternal love that loved me so much
and don't forget he is told us that her love is greater than all creatures put together her maternal
love that loved me so much would have made her succumb therefore come you who do not have the
love of my mother you can do it you don't have her love you won't be affected the same way
isn't i amazing come to sustain my little arms and to try my tears this is the same as Moses on the
mountain interceding for the people in Exodus 17 verses 11 to 13 and Aaron and her having to hold
up his arms so that he could continue till evening i want you to place and i love you of your own
upon the ground against which my little knees were leaning so that it may not be so hard for me and
then throw yourself into my little arms that i may offer you to my celestial father as the daughter
of my will even from the time i called you now that's a big turn on even from that time so i want
to give you Jeremiah one five you were called before you came into existence and Galatians 115 as well
there are others i could give you but that's enough even from that time i called you and when i saw
myself alone abandoned by all i would say to myself if everyone leaves me the newborn of my will
will never leave me alone isolation is too hard for me because god is love so my acts await yours
and your company now this is asked of louisa in a very big way and of us in a lesser way
who can say all that my sweet Jesus made present to me of all the activists life if i wanted to tell
them all it would be too long it would take an entire volumes to do it so she moves on after
this i was saying to my beloved Jesus my love now she's revisiting something we've had a discussion
about a number of times before and it illustrates something very important for us that you can tell
people something and you can tell them three or four times more as well they won't remember you said
it because they didn't think about it she said my love if you so much love that your most holy
will be known and reigned with its full dominion in the midst of creatures why didn't you form
together with redemption the fulfillment of your most holy will when you came upon the earth united
with our celestial mother who just as she obtained the longed for redeemer would obtain the longed
for fiat as you can see we've had this discussion many times your visible presence would have helped
and facilitated the kingdom of the supreme wheel upon earth in an admirable way but doing it through
this poor wretched and incapable creature it seems to me that it wouldn't have all the glory and the
total triumph now having been shown the great distance between Jesus and his mother the great
distance between his mother and us you can understand louisa coming back to the point and saying hey sure
you haven't made a mistake in choosing someone as small as me and my Jesus moving in my interior
told me my daughter everything was established ab a turno in that single act of the divine will
everything's established the epoch and the time both for redemption and that for the divine will
to be made known upon the earth so that it should reign so god's kyros time that god's time for
intervention in human affairs is established ab a turno we can't change that it was established
that my redemption was to serve as a means of help redemption had not been the origin of man
now if you have your book with you make sure you color that redemption had not been the origin of
man but it arose as a means after man moved away from his origin moved away from the divine will
on the other hand my will was the origin of man because the gift was given to adam at the very
beginning and this is the end to which he must enclose himself so supposing somebody lives in
the human will for the whole of their lives death plunges them into the divine will and that's that
he's going to make that very clear you may get away with the human will when you're on planet earth
as soon as you leave it there's nothing outside of planet earth except the divine will or hell
so all things have their origin from my will and everything must return to it and if not everyone
will do it in time no one will be able to escape at an eternity therefore also for this reason
the primacy is always my will now in order to form redemption we've been through all this before
i needed a virgin mother conceived without the shadow of original sin because having to take
human flesh it was right and just for me the eternal word not to take an infected blood to form my
most holy humanity let's have a cook one thirteen god can't even look on sin and Hebrews 12 14
now in order to make my will known so that it might rain i do not need to have a second mother
according to the natural order that is a second mother in the flesh for the divine will but rather
i need a second mother according to the order of grace now if you go back to volume two Jesus made
luisa his second mother the mother according to grace to bring the divine will upon the earth
in fact in order for my will to reign i have no need of another humanity but to give such
knowledge of the divine will that drawn by its prodigies by its beauty by its sanctity and by
the immense good that comes from it souls may submit with all love to its dominion now notice
all love the lord does not want any robots in his kingdom he does not want any slaves he does
not want any prisoners that's all earth stuff the only people he wants in his divine will is somebody
who surrenders with love because your love is small l is surrendering to love with a capital l
god is love therefore in choosing you for the mission of my will he said i took you from the
common stock according to the natural order that means born with original sin and born in the ordinary
way but for the decorum of my will i had to raise you so high now according to the order of grace
now erasing you so high go back to volume one and she had three spiritual marriages before the age
of 20 because there was a lot of work to be done so the lord brought her to a stage that in earlier
generations nobody thought any creature could be brought to that level john of the cross in the
16th century said reaching union with god was the highest experience a human person could have on
the earth and so luisa has three spiritual marriages before she's 20 so i had to raise you so high
according to the order of grace that not one infected shadow might remain in your soul now
here you are being told the reason why luisa was given so much grace god doesn't give us grace
just for the fun of it he actually is trying to accomplish something he's trying to get somewhere
and so since luisa was born with original sin he wanted to remove absolutely every effect
not one infected shadow might remain in your soul because of which my will might feel reluctant
to reign in you now please if you have your own book will you color that the divine will
is reluctant to reign in us if we are submitting to the human will and we're being stubborn and
rebellious and selfish and self-centered that's not the place where the divine will wants to reign
what we're dealing with is the crown of sanctity the absolute top that is possible the highest
position that's possible for human beings and therefore while he hasn't given us the grace that
he's given to luisa that there's not one infected shadow at the same time he is expecting us to
reach the highest possible position we can just as the pure blood of the immaculate virgin pure
blood means no sin no trace of sin no infected shadow and so on just as this was needed to form
my humanity to be able to redeem man so was the purity the candidness the sanctity and the beauty
of your soul needed to form in you the life of my divine will color that in your own personal book
please in order for the divine will to reign in us the lord needs purity of mind heart and body in
us candidness is this simplicity and openness no shadow of twistedness or deception or anything like
that completely open the sanctity the beauty of your soul all of that is needed if you're going to
live in the divine will and just as by forming my humanity in the womb of my mother this humanity
gave itself to all souls it's understood to those who wanted he puts in brackets because god won't
force either redemption or sanctification or his divine will on anybody it's the exact opposite
to satan's kingdom that if satan gets a foothold at all he imprisons and he absolutely crushes
people the lord will only do this for us if we willingly actually want it and that's very important
it's no harm to ask yourself every now and then how much of this do i want it's understood
i give it to those who want it and it's given as a means of salvation light and sanctity in the same
way this life of my will which has been formed in you will give itself to all souls to make itself
known and to acquire its dominion so our blessed mother was brought to the height that she had to be
brought to in order to have the physical presence of the incarnate world within her
louisa is brought to the height that is required in order for the divine will to be able to establish
its reign as well and the lord will bring us to the height that we're willing to go to let him use
us as well so the next one is that the divine will is for everyone who wants it
had i wanted to free you from original sin as i did with my celestial mother so that my will
might take life in you watch this now this is very very important no one that means the rest of us
would have given it a thought they would not even have considered letting my will reign within
themselves they would have said what needs to be a second mother of jesus and i have all her privileges
so that the life of the divine will could reign and as we draw it off on the other hand by knowing
that you are of their stock that means you were born with original sin you were conceived just like
them if they wanted now notice this now that willingness helped by their own goodwill they too
will be able to know the supreme will he's made it as easy as possible for us they will
know what they must do to let it reign within them they will know the good that comes to them
and they will know the terrestrial and the celestial happiness prepared in a distinct way
for those who will let my will reign there's a lot in that and i find that if you would
separate it into one two three four five it makes an awful lot of sense my redemption was to serve
to plant the tree of my will that's the tree of life which number one watered by my blood
number two cultivated and hold with my sweats and unheard of pains number three fertilized
with the sacraments and i want to give you the tree that's the mustard seed or the tree of life
at the mustard seed is Matthew 13 31 at 32 john 15 is the i am divine so he is the tree okay then
what would you find first it would make the tree develop letting all this happen would make the
tree develop it would make the flowers bloom and thirdly finally make the celestial fruits
that's Galatians 520 the fruits of the spirit mature and in order to make the precious fruits
mature the course of my 33 years was not enough nor were souls prepared and disposed to receive a
food so delicate now what Jesus is doing here is explaining why he had to wait 2000 years
so what he did during his 33 years that wasn't enough and what happened was that humanity wasn't
ready and you know that if a person isn't ready for something they can't cooperate
if you put astrophysics in front of a six-year-old you're wasting your time they're not ready
put it in front of a 26-year-old and it might be different so the creatures were not prepared
nor were they disposed to receive a food so delicate which is all of heaven their spirits were now
ready to receive this heavenly food therefore i contented myself with number one planting the
tree number two leaving all possible means to make it grow beautiful and gigantic that's the mustard
seed up and number three at the appropriate time which is 2000 years later as the fruits were about
to mature and so that they may be picked i chose you in a way all special to make known to you the
good it contains and how i want to raise the creature back to her origin so he's explaining to her
why it actually took the time and we all know that anything you want to achieve
and you want it to mature it takes time now the soul who would come into the divine will
banishing her will put a huge huge mark around that because if you don't
banish your will and surrender your will at every moment you're not going anywhere in the divine
will that's the sacrifice that's required so banishing her will the cause for which she descended from
her happy state she will eat of these precious fruits at your Galatians 522 which will give her
such taste as to remove her from all infection of passions therefore someone living in the divine
will seriously is not sinning sinning is the exact opposite of what we're talking about we're talking
about somebody surrendering at every moment of their being and being purified at every moment of
their being and therefore the infection of passions and of our own will are dealt with and the lord
would give back the dominion of his will to us embracing everything as though in one single embrace
my will will unite everything together creation redemption and the fulfillment of the purpose for
which all things were created that is that my will be known loved and done on earth as it is
in heaven that means that when it comes about that enough of us actually surrender to the divine will
and allow the divine will to put its throne on the earth in us and that the kingdom of the divine
will can spread then he will bring it all together just in one act so Louisa answered him Jesus my love
the more you tell me the more I feel the weight of my littleness and I feared that I might be an
obstacle to the kingdom of your divine will on earth oh if you and my mother had done this directly
while being on the earth your will would have had all its effect so I want to give you two Corinthians
two 16 and two Corinthians three versus four to five for that Jesus interrupted her and said my daughter
the last bit here really made me laugh I don't know if you'll get it unless I give it to you very
plain our task he said was perfectly accomplished now you'll be attentive to accomplishing yours
get on with that he's saying just put your mind on it and do it okay this is your task more so
since the sovereign queen and I are untouchable by pains now you'd have to say we are in the state
of impassivity and of complete glory and therefore pains can no longer have ending to do with us
therefore the visions that Louisa has been continuously receiving in the early volumes seeing Jesus in
desperate pain has to do with the kingdom of god on earth now it's a graphic picture she's seeing
he's in heaven he can suffer no longer so we're in the state of impassivity and of complete glory
and therefore pains can no longer have anything to do with us you on the contrary have the pains
as help motivation and insight to infiltrate the supreme fiat in other words you need something
to really go to to do this and therefore all the trials and difficulties that are coming upon us
in the present time and in the years to come will be our motivation to do it as well
so you have this as help and means you have new knowledge and you get new graces
and even though I am in heaven I will be hidden inside of you to form the kingdom of my will
so there you see the by location he's in heaven and he's in us my power is always the same
while being in heaven I can do what I would have done while being visible on the earth
because he's god with god all things are possible when I want it and the creature
lends herself in other words there's our cooperation giving all of herself
pray to my will I invest her and I make her do what I myself should do therefore be attentive
and mind your own task let's put that in ordinary English mind your own business
you're minding my business and you're minding blessed mother's business
and what happened before and all the rest would you just simply concentrate on what god is
asking of you and if we would do that what he's asking of us is to really get into the divine will
more and more surrender our human will more and more deeply and let him triumph in us
I've kept you a little bit long tonight but I wanted to finish that not less than thank you